for the first time we are now seeing
body cam video of officers arriving to
the scene of a deadly crash thanks for
staying with us at 4 30. I'm Denise
Valdez I'm Kirsten Joyce a 13 year old
was killed in Henderson by a driver
going nearly 100 miles per hour in a 35
mile per hour Zone that driver was
sentenced to six years in prison but his
8 news now reporter Joshua paguera found
the 22 year old driver nor his friends
were ever tested for substances
Henderson police showed up to a hectic
scene
13-year-old Rex pageant was killed while
walking home in front of Manion middle
school and police detained four people
including Jose marmalejo the driver of a
black Mustang Jose right
[Music]
[Applause]
I know right from when you hit that bump
it just did you did it fishtail what
happened
[Music]
body cam footage shows police talking to
the four adults as they're sitting right
here they blocked off the whole area so
no one was allowed to come in and right
there at this corner was a black mangled
Mustang the vehicle that hit wrecks
responding officers asked him how fast
was he traveling you could just give a
approximate
80 miles
hey 80 possibly prosecutors revealed
during his sentencing that marmalejo was
in fact driving nearly 100 miles per
hour police questioned him again on what
happened did you guys roll at all or is
it just you
but what wasn't asked has a father of
Rex Patchett upset for the end of the
influence of any alcohol or or substance
was the was that part of the the
questioning that was was asked of the
defendant there wasn't any evidence in
court records that police conducted a
fuel sobriety test inexcusable that
someone could engage a behavior like
this kill an individual and there's no
Reasonable Suspicion to do field
sobriety tests